so Tom thanks for your kind words I go
back a long way to Stanford I came to
Stanford in 1992 on a fellowship to
pursue my PhD in electrical engineering
but I dropped out of it like many of I
students do and I came to this country
with $500 and I can't thank Stanford
enough for making me what I am today I
would also like to thank the entire stvp
staff the Department of Electrical
Engineering which gives immigrants like
me an opportunity to thrive in this
country so I start by welcoming each one
of you to my talk today
I was wondering should I start by saying
good afternoon or should I start by
saying good evening
the VC's typically start the day at this
time by saying good evening but students
having been an alum myself I know we
work till midnight so this really is
afternoon so good afternoon everybody
I'm Naveen Chadha from Mayfield it's a
real pleasure to be with you all here
today one thing I always remember when I
was at Stanford the winter quarter used
to be the easiest it was a breeze I hope
it's still the case are you guys with me
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding I like
sharing jokes and being making sarcastic
comments I have another problem
having been a Stanford alum I like doing
last-minute things so I got here early I
was roaming around a lot of people saw
me outside I was roaming around on
campus and something struck me and being
a perfectionist I said hmm I need to
make some changes to my slides in order
to talk about it but I got vetoed by my
team so what I'm going to do is before I
get into my talk I want to share some of
my thoughts my understanding serving on
the board of the Stanford venture
engineering fund along with tennis team
VC's is that the skills required to
succeed at Stanford have grown
exponentially since my days on campus
almost twenty years back but not much
has changed on the biking front I used
to do this I'm seeing many of you do
this
I still see students biking without
helmets hands-free holding cups of
coffee checking email texting and even
posting selfies I assume none of you
guys do that but for the record I used
to do it there were no Instagram and
there was no snapchat but I used to do a
lot of those things but I'm supposed to
talk here today about entrepreneurship
it's the ETL Series so you must be
wondering what did this guy drink before
coming here I just had a cup of coffee
at Cooper coffee so be careful of what
you drink there I don't know what they
mixed in there but here is the real
reason why I'm doing that I see a lot of
parallels in the way you bike with what
entrepreneurship is about you're living
at the edge by biking hands-free you are
taking risk by not wearing helmets
you're multitasking by doing text
posting pictures which is what
entrepreneurs do so tell me if my
observations are correct because I'm
seeing future entrepreneurs in you I see
a lot of nods are there in the audience
well jokes apart now we can get back to
the slides that were prepared I'm here
to talk about some rules of the road for
building iconic companies as you heard
from Tom Mayfield has been in business
for over 50 years and we have partnered
with thousands of innovators many of
whom who came from Stanford and have
gone on to create iconic comments
however if there's one thing I want you
to remember from my talk today
it's that company building is a marathon
it's not a sprint there'll be a lot of
ups and downs it won't be easy it
requires patience
it requires perseverance and grit but
believe me from my own experiences as a
serial entrepreneur the journey is well
worth it let me start with my own
journey which is an example of this
belief as probably you can tell from my
accent and my looks
many people think I'm not from India but
I am from India I went to Indian
Institute of Technology graduated at the
top of the class like many other Indian
students came to Stanford University I
was blessed with a fellowship with $500
to pursue my masters and PhD in
electrical engineering back in the early
90s the internet was happening based on
my PhD work I started my first company
via Xtreme which enabled the delivery of
video on the Internet the basic idea was
how do you take Stanford lectures which
were being broadcasted with in
classrooms were available in video tapes
in the Turman Center and make it
available over the internet once we did
that all we see said this is Netscape
for video and they start chasing us I
was confused I've come to this country
to study I'm pursuing a PhD degree I
need to drop off I call my parents I
called my friends they were shocked you
really are going to drop off out of your
ph.d program well somehow they were nice
professors my mentors they said why
don't you take a one-year leave of
absence and go to this company most
likely you're gonna fail and you want to
come back and finish your PhD degree but
life didn't have that we extreme grew
extremely fast and became the de facto
standard for streaming video on the
internet getting used by most of the
media companies and also by corporations
and 18 months into our founding we were
acquired by Microsoft to become Windows
Media once an entrepreneur always an
entrepreneur you taste success it's like
lions you taste blood you want more of
it so I went on to start to other
companies after we extreme one of them
was called ib m-- broadcasting which
went public in 2000 no better time to go
public in 2000 especially in May of 2000
and then you go ordered a billion traded
a three billion and by end of the year
you back to two hundred million and you
scratch your head and you say what
happened and I read a book and it said
somebody moved my cheese I'm still
wondering who moved it I think it was
the stock market and the hedge funds no
offense to any of them in the room then
I did my second company my third company
after that which was review a software
as a service company for small
businesses ten years early of its time
which ended up getting acquired by see
fear calm which is still a thriving
business focused on the CPA market
post the acquisition of the extreme I
became one of the youngest execs at
Microsoft at the age of 26 worked very
closely with Satya Nadella
the current president and CEO of
Microsoft we were both peers
I was running Windows Media he was
running Microsoft's commerce server
learnt a lot of what it takes to run
companies at scale and to take that
knowledge I joined the venture capital
business by accident in 2004 I had gone
in as an entrepreneur in residence to
start my fourth company I didn't know
anything about venture capital I just
had fun creating companies and having
impact I've been a VC for over 14 years
now I've been leading Mayfield as the
managing partner for over 10 years I've
invested in over 50 companies have been
extremely fortunate to have partnered
with world-class entrepreneurs who
created companies 16 of which have had I
POS and another 18 have been acquired
god bless them for the work they do and
make the life of VCS like my easy no
switch let's switch gears to Mayfield
and I like asking a lot of questions
I'm known at Mayfield I put people on
the spot I ask questions but I do give
awards so Mayfield as you heard from Tom
was started in 1969 and has its roots at
Stanford University any takers without
searching on the internet and none of
the professor's please where did the
name may feel come from the people who
get it right in the first five seconds
will get an award which will be handed
by my colleague Kelsey so here you go
watch - yes is their street called me
tell your baby you got it you got it
what's your name sir good good
so Mayfield was founded in 1969 it
wasn't founded to your answer on
Mayfield Avenue which is next to where
the frat parties happen neither was it
formed after the name of Mayfield bakery
where we get great coffee and great
things to eat so Mayfield you're
absolutely right was after the name of a
thriving town called Mayfield which
preceded Palo Alto fast forward 50 years
what is Mayfield about we're a people
first organization where we bet on
people first market second we believe on
betting on the jockey not the racetrack
our strong belief is if you invest in a
plus people their initial idea may not
be the right one but they'll quickly
pivot to find the right market
opportunity we are partnering with
entrepreneurs who want to change the way
in which we work live and play our
entire team has an entrepreneurial DNA
and operational background where we have
been in the shoes of the entrepreneurs
and realize how lonely that job is and
how difficult it is to be an
entrepreneur and in our 50 year track
record we have raised 18 funds to date
invested in over 500 companies 200 of
which have been acquired another 116
have had IPOs and we have an expert
network of over 500 cxos who help our
companies from time to time as needed
believe me I'm going to get to the
stories but wanted to just rather than
introducing me introduce Mayfield and I
know I'll keep it to 25 minutes for sure
as Tom mentioned thanks to the great
work his organization has done in stvp
we are proud sponsors of the Mayfield
Fellows Program I see some faces here
who have
INEX Mayfield Fellows the program was
endowed in 1995 it chooses 12 students
every years to help them become leaders
of tomorrow Tom just told me it's
becoming a very popular program and let
me see if I get the numbers right being
an electrical engineer
there were 112 applications that applied
56 were interviewed and you chose 12 is
that right okay I passed the program
also has over 250 alumni many of whom
might be in the room they have started
companies like Instagram or are working
at startups and well is that well
established companies if you are not
thinking of pursuing an MBA if you're
getting into your third year at Stanford
I highly recommend go talk to Tom Byers
he's the best in helping people get to
this right let's move gears and now I'm
going to get into the crux of the stuff
write about the rules of the road for
building iconic companies so as you
heard from Tom Mayfield is a built to
last organization very few venture firms
we can count maybe two or three are
celebrating their 50th year in business
and this will apply as you think about
building iconic companies yourself one
day so the firm has some fundamental
beliefs on which we are built if we
cannot see eye-to-eye with the
entrepreneur on these beliefs we won't
invest in them really tell them we are
the wrong partner for you so what's the
first one our motto is people first as I
mentioned earlier we bet on people
market second because people build
companies companies don't build people
we are known for embracing the
unconventional the different and the
unusual which means we are typically
backing people
who don't come from central casting I
was a good example when I started my
first company at 25 most of the VC said
hey you don't have an MBA degree you
don't have right here but today I can go
and say hey it's okay I don't have white
hair but I have no hair or have very
little hair if you help our other belief
is that great people evolve which means
CEOs are made not born if you want to do
it you can do it forth
we are loyal to a fault we believe if
company building is a marathon we need
to be running along with the
entrepreneur through the ups and downs
through the taken things sometimes we
are carrying bottles of water when they
get exhausted and believe me sometimes
we are carrying their sweaty cloths they
use to do things I won't get into we
don't beat around the bush because we
believe in radical candor in any
partnership is very important to speak
the truth and don't take too long to
communicate the messages we believe
experience counts for something both as
a firm as an individual and finally the
most important belief Mayfield has is
it's all about teamwork this is not a
solo sport companies cannot be built
around one individuals all of us are
better than any of us now over the next
15 minutes I'm going to share some
learnings what I'm calling rules of the
road that we have gathered from
partnering with thousands of innovators
over the past 50 years I can go for a
day I can go for a week I can go for a
month but I'm going to be writing a book
so be prepared but for today I'm only
going to share five lessons which I
think are good enough to get started
because I don't want you guys dying off
in
digestion I want you to die of
starvation so for the time I've been
given I want to focus on five examples
which you can all relate to that are
about current companies so let's get
going my first story is about left I'm
sure all of us in the room use it not
their competitor home I won't mention is
that the case how many people this is
for prize number two how many people in
the room know who Zimride was five
seconds cars cars but you're almost deep
he gets the second award so this story
what sad yes I'll say that right I'll
tell the story so and the talk I was
told it's better to tell these examples
through stories rather than the result
right so when we met John and Logan in
2011 their business was called same
right as lyft didn't even exist what was
the idea the idea was a social site a
variant of Craigslist where people were
posting requests and offers for shared
rights it was primarily being used by
students primarily at Stanford and
commuters for the Bay Area traffic but
it wasn't a direct consumer to consumer
application it was distributed through
universities and corporations it was a
good idea but not a massive market that
a VC would invest it then comes the
smartphone revolution and the smartphone
step like any other smart entrepreneur
John and Logan pivoted the company to
creating the first now this is debatable
I'm an investor in them so please take
it with a grain of salt
the first peer-to-peer ride-sharing
service not focused on the black car
market and have grown in seven years or
so to providing more than 50 million
rides a month what led to their success
was their authentic mission of making
people's lives better by providing the
best transportation not only did they
have an authentic mission from day one
they also had a set of core values any
guesses on what they were 5 seconds 1 2
3 4 5 I get this award their values
still are be yourself
uplift others and make things happen and
I still remember it because I just can't
forget it given their mission of making
people's lives better supporting local
and global communities is a big priority
they walk the walk and talk the talk
this is one of the most mission driven
company I have seen in my career as a VC
and entrepreneur over the last 25 years
they walk the walk as I said and they
talk the talk they provide free rides to
tolls to poles they're supporting
California fire victims and in many
cases outside the United States they are
transporting people stuck in weather
conditions to get them to warming
centers so what's the lesson if you have
to build a company which can achieve a
valuation over 15 billion a foundational
company which I'm sure many people in
the room want to do codify your mission
and values on day one if you don't have
that thing
about you're going to build a 50-story
building and the foundation is in there
is going to fall it'll be the Millennial
top you don't want that you want to
create a real company so start with the
right mission and the right set of
values my seconds and I'm gonna be
cheating I'm only talking about unicorns
and Penta Khan's and deco Khan's today
right I can also come next time and talk
about companies which didn't work my
second story is about a company called
mark arrow the leader in the marketing
automation space in 2006 when digital
and email marketing were going
mainstream Phil and his co-founders had
the mission of transforming art
transforming marketing from an art or
science and elevate the role of
marketeers any people in the room
thinking of becoming marketers raise of
hands good good I know you're a market
here right so what did they do they
always wanted to start small by solving
a simple problem which was very critical
for their customers but always had the
vision to create an end-to-end platform
for marketing the first product was
about management of Google AdWords for
search marketing the product met with
limited success you all know how hard it
is to build a scalable business and
Google separate story separate chapter
of another book but let's focus on what
happened these people were tenacious
they didn't give up they went back to
the drawing board because they believed
company building is a marathon not a
sprint
one of the core values was listening to
customers first and foremost based on
listening to customers they expanded and
came up with a new product for lead
manage
for b2b market ears which was the
easiest to use in the market and became
the underpinnings for the end-to-end
marketing platform they worked
tirelessly not only to educate market
ears but also to elevate their roles in
organizations from being enablers to
drivers of revenues growth they not only
created a category they created a
movement marquee donation a community of
tens of thousands of marketeers think
github for marketers why was Mark arrow
so successful they decided to focus on
one functional area marketing they
didn't go and D focus and said I'll
solve a problem in sales one day an HR
one day in support that this doesn't
work so what did they do rather than
going an inch deep in solving problems
in many areas they build trenches in
solving the problems in one area and
rather than being a jack-of-all-trades
they became a king of on hill what
followed Marketo became one of the
fastest growing SAS companies in the
marketing automation space when public
in 2013 and was acquired by Adobe
recently for 5 billion so the key lesson
is focus when you're building a company
as startups die of indigestion not
starvation my third story is about Solar
City today seeing solar panels on homes
is becoming fairly common however that
was not the case in 2006 for that reason
Lyndon and his brother Peter and their
cousin the famous Elon Musk came up with
Solar City the initial idea was they
would install and maintain solar panels
people's homes but there was one problem
with it everybody had to fork out 30 50
hundred K up front and the ROI was 15 16
17 years and people didn't want to do
that
so the initial business met with limited
success not unlike other entrepreneurs
they said hmm what can we do so they did
the same thing they went and talked to
customers they talked to advisors they
talked to mentors and they came up with
a simple business model in 2009-2010
where they said why don't we go back to
customers and say you pay us on a
monthly basis on a leasing model similar
to what you pay your electricity company
what followed people were used to buying
electricity in that way the example I
would give is I want to have a pizza I
know how to pay for it rather than
selling me a pizza which is already
ready-to-eat you're giving me all the
ingredients and saying make it on your
own and pay for it up front
neither do I have the time neither do I
have this acumen so sell products in the
way people are used to consuming so
what's the summary this non-technical
innovation made solar city a breakout
company they generated billions of
dollars in revenues went public in 2012
and achieve a market cap of over 5
billion and were eventually acquired by
Tesla so as you look at starting your
next company
I know it's Stanford I'm a EE don't just
think about technical innovation broaden
your horizon think about other forms of
innovation I already talked about one
with business model through solar city
think about innovation in go-to-market
and distribution similar to what leading
open source companies are doing and at
the same time think about innovation in
delivery models what companies like
Salesforce and AWS
doing on the delivery front so think
innovation has many forms and you can
innovate across the value chain my next
story is off mode and I'm going to pick
it up mote is the leader in digital
media advertising measurement I don't
know if you guys know the most
successful brand advertising campaigns
online are the ones which sell sarees
and are memorable for that reason
coca-cola Nike Unilever and Apple are
the gold standards however even I didn't
know this before I went on and invested
in this company as a firm that half the
money more advertisers spend on brand
advertising is wasted the bigger problem
is they don't even know on what so the
big pain point they face is to measure
the effectiveness of their digital brand
advertising to solve that problem Jonah
and his co-founders started more in 2010
they looked at existing solutions they
always are they were models like
pay-per-click paper impressions they
looked at it and they said hey this just
doesn't work and rather than doing
incremental innovation they went back to
the drawing board talked to customers
and came up with a simple product which
was a google-like search engine to tell
brand advertisers where on the internet
are the most effective brand campaigns
running so it was a competitive
intelligence engine for competitors
based on that they expanded companies
never stopped they learned the pivot and
they expand they expanded into providing
an analytics platform which measured
attention and engagement what followed
all major online brands in
including Internet companies like Snap
Facebook once a leader snapchat all
became their customers they became the
fastest growing company and the Nielsen
equal length of digital brand
advertising and were acquired by Oracle
for a hefty amount so what do I want to
communicate in summary here make sure
the product or service you're building
is a must-have for your customers
because painkiller cell vitamins don't
my last and favorite example is of a
company called Poshmark I know my friend
Manish had appeared last year right for
an ETL talk so let me be quick with this
story Poshmark was founded in 2011 and
there were many unbelievers most of the
people didn't believe that selling used
fashion through a marketplace online was
a big idea
however Mayfield is a people first
investor we don't care what the idea is
we're making the bet on the jockey I
know nothing about fashion as you can
see with the way I dress we made a bet
on Manish and gave him a term sheet even
before he had started a company and
connected him to his co-founder Tracy
who had great background in fashion and
merchandising fast forward to today the
company has expanded beyond use fashion
they have expanded beyond women's
fashion they're selling men's fashion
new I don't buy used you can see it may
not be the best but it's Michael Kors
and Joe's right like what notes Tom's
tells so pretty so they have expanded
from men's from women to men's to kids
to beauty for both new and used fashion
I'm pleased to further report
a sale is made on Poshmark every second
and they're over five million sellers
who are selling goods from their closets
online and they're over 40 million
community members the platform has deep
engagement it's number three and
engagement after Facebook and Instagram
users are opening the application five
to seven times a day spending 27 minutes
on it the millions of social
interactions every day when an item is
posted and 80% of the daily shoppers are
repeat buyers however the main reason
this company is so successful is because
they embrace a people first philosophy
Manish when he came here talked about
and he still says it every day Poshmark
is all about love it's all about
customer first so let me give an example
in the early days when Poshmark didn't
have enough people manish himself tried
to solve every customer request from
7:00 a.m. to 11:00 p.m. daily now we
know that's no way to build a
sustainable company but what does it
speak to it speaks to the tenacity of
the company it speak to the culture of
customer first as a result to this state
the maximum number of employees in the
company and not in technology they're in
customer success and customer support
more than 40% of the employees are in
that organization when we are just a
marketplace we don't even touch the
goods which are sold on our platform so
in summary the lesson is if you have to
build an enduring company start with
people end with people take a people
centric
approach in western relationships don't
invest in transactions people could be
your employees people could be your
customers people could be your partners
they could be your vendors it could be
anybody it could be even giving back to
the community you do good
which Poshmark is doing good happens to
you to summarize my five rules of the
road first and foremost you need to
codify your mission and values as they
are critical second focus a startups die
of indigestion not starvation third
innovate across the value change don't
just get Box down into tech innovation
make sure your product is a must-have
because painkiller sell vitamins don't
and finally embrace a people first
philosophy but I said at the beginning
of the talk remember one thing all that
stuff I told you the slides will be
available you might forget but remember
one thing
company building is a marathon not a
sprint it's not for the faint of heart
there'll be many lessons you will learn
every day and keep a nimble mind if you
know all the answers don't do a company
if you don't know the answers like the
way you bike like the way you take the
risk jump and do a company now I'm in
front of an audience which are
overachievers so I'm just wondering
right like what should I tell you at the
end right I want to share some tips with
you remember I talked about remember
only one thing company building is a
marathon not a sprint
I don't know about you but I can speak
for myself I'm never going to go run a
marathon or climb Mount Everest unless I
practice unless I train unless I read
similarly I think a lot of you people
since you're taking these classes are
eager to
out of the company but I want to share
some tips and some lessons that you
should keep in mind before you get
started the first one is start with the
disruptive and big idea but make sure
it's a painkiller and not a vitamin
check with customers talk to customers
not one not three not your friends
the vast majority the world is noisy
there are too many products too many
solutions people don't have time
second surround yourself with
experienced mentors there's many of them
in this room you have professors you
have executives you have VC's I would go
to them last because there's always a
negotiation on tries but make sure these
experienced mentors have seen the movie
before you should make new mistakes not
all mistakes find great co-founders they
need to be complimentary to you and
don't need to just say yes to everything
you say that's very very important
fourth as I mentioned define your
company mission and values it's like the
foundation everything starts and ends at
there a weak foundation you can build as
tall a building is going to fall one day
v MOV see this advisors not a VC this is
a very critical decision I was a
three-time founder you need to make sure
you pick the right investors we
interview you we check your references
on sheet of sheet why won't you do that
on us right I've invested in 50
companies pick up the phone I'm also a
human I must have some good things I
have some blind spots see if there's a
match can I be complimentary or con can
the investor you are choosing be
complimentary two things you need and
finally
most importantly this is not an easy
road it's harder said than done
smell the roses along the way and enjoy
the journey in the end you can read
books I can give you as many talks I can
write books you can attend many schools
you can get many mentors remember one
thing besides running a marathon and not
a sprint in the end you are the ones who
make it happen and since you are
attending this class I am a very I'm a
person with a lot of a Dede but I pick
things very quickly so this is what I
found outside the stvp office that's not
part of my talk I just picked it first
like you bike and you take risk bear
like an entrepreneur second dream like a
disrupter and finally I have to read
this it's in some cursive font so it's
not easy to read I'm just kidding I like
kidding we'll be faced with a lot of
problems in life but remember it's a
marathon it's not a sprint all of us are
blessed to be in this room to be in
Silicon Valley where money is easily
available mentors are easily available
so every time you get a problem look at
it as an opportunity and finally I would
like to end by Andy Grove saying hey
your failure as an entrepreneur is very
important your failure this year is an
opportunity to succeed next year so
please keep these things I'm sharing
with you today in mind
because it's time for you guys as you
graduate to make the jump take risk
think big that most what will happen
you'll learn something then get started
again if you fight if you fall from a
bike you don't stop biking you just run
to the small place they give you some
injections they tie you the stuff and
you're back to the races so that's what
I had on the official stuff
[Applause]